à vous lire merci là on retrouve
françois rebsamen pour la deuxième
partie de cette voie est libre
c'était l'information hier soir le
retour de nicolas sarkozy françois
rebsamen alors bon on s'en doutait on
voyait venir est-ce que tout va changer
dans la vie politique française
voit non rien n'a changé parce qu'il
n'est pas partir et essaie toujours là
et elle a par concert interposés les
autres donc il n'y eut être président je
crois du de l'ump
donc c'est son droit le plus strict
on a beaucoup parlé des affaires qui le
concernent est ce que vous pensez qu'il
s'en sortira ce que vous pensez qu'il
revient pour échapper à ces affaires non
non je pense pas je pense pas la justice
passera dire si oui ou non il est en
responsabilité sur deux les dossiers sur
lesquels il est poursuivi je sais même
plus y en a tellement des vrais des faux
bond j'en sais rien je vais vous dire
quelque chose ça m'intéresse plus ça me
passionne pas le retour de sarkozy ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de voir comment un
grand parti comme l'ump va retrouver
j'allais dire une voix parce que
aujourd'hui ses 20 propositions
différentes c'est un problème pour nous
parce qu'il se reprenne pour les
français parce que
quand ils disent bah c'est pas assez on
va pas assez loin dans les économies
faut faire 100 milliards ou 150
milliards vous en faites que ça compte
puisqu'il veut le faire supprimer les
postes de profs comisa fr et le débat
démocratique a besoin c'est ce que
disait manuel valls de se présenter
projet contre projet c'est moi je
respecte les formations politiques quand
elle présente des projets quel est le
projet de l'ump aujourd'hui ça serait
bien fichu de le dire à part le retour
de nicolas sarkozy c'est quoi ça manuel
valls a frappé fort en disant que le fn
était aux portes du pouvoir si vous êtes
d'accord est ce qu il a exagéré c'est
une posture une manoeuvre non ce jeu je
crois que c'est pas exactement la phrase
je pense qu'il a dit qu' il faudrait pas
que
fn se retrouve aux portes du pouvoir
donc c'est pas la même chose mais c'est
vrai que c'est très excitant de voir la
montée du fn s'est on peut dire ce qu'on
veut moi je ne traite pas les membres du
fn de fasciste je sais bien que mais là
à côté populiste rejet de l'autre qui
fait que le fn est un parti à part dans
la république donc c'est un parti qui
véhiculent des idées qui sont pas qu'ils
sont pas bonnes pour la république c'est
cette idée du rejet de l'autre est
toujours présente du repli sur soi comme
si on pouvait sortir comme ça de
l'europe ou de l'hérault ou de l'euro
alors que ça ferait des dégâts chez les
plus pauvres c'est évidemment
justement c'est à nous d'expliquer et
peut-être ne vivons-nous plus assez en
contact avec ces gens ne les voyons nous
pas assez je parle pas pour moi à dijon
parce que j'ai connais je vais je les
vois ces rencontres mais des
parlementaires socialistes des deux
peut-être une distance qui s'est faite
entre la classe politique en général
bon la droite c'est son problème mais je
parle de la gauche qui les portent ces
valeurs là et c'est milieux populaires
je voyais le décalage ma déclaration
elle a été brocardée par tout le monde
et tout et j'ai reçu des centaines de
témoignages de soutien de gens dans les
milieux populaires parce que quand vous
vivez dans un hlm dans un quartier
populaire nous lient au milieu des
autres et vous voyez les autres quand tu
te bouffer dans une maison à l'écart
dans un abri et derrière un code digital
voyez pas les autres et donc je pense
que ça c'est un décalage le fn mais voit
pas plus mais aujourd'hui
avec les échecs les noms résultat les
noms résultats échecs successifs la
droite et de la gauche qui font monter
le fn aujourd'hui oui oui je le pense je
le pense c'est pour ça qu'il faut des
résultats seuls les résultats comptent
aujourd'hui et le sort personnel des uns
et des autres n'a pas d'accord si vous
n'avez pas les résultats que vous vous
est compté est ce que pour le coup la
phrase de manuel valls prend son sens
oui bien sûr et moi je moi je vis déjà
comme une presque une souffrance le fait
que le fn ait fait 13% à 10 ans même si
on arrivait à le maintenir
voilà mais j'ai je vis ça comme une
commune souffrance parce que dans une
ville où on porte vivre ensemble je
trouve ça regrettable faut dire que la
droite locale n'est pas à la hauteur un
mémoire
justement il ya sur internet jeanne nous
nous dit françois rebsamen ne regrettent
ils pas être engagés dans cette galère
au lieu de rester tranquillement à dijon
ac c'est la question que je me suis
posée quand le président de la
république m'a m'a proposé j'ai refusé
deux fois et je me suis dit à un moment
je peux pas rester il faut que je mette
ses mains dans le cambouis sinon on dira
il n'a pas il veut pas se faire comme
les autres et pas le courage
vous êtes vraiment posé la question
pourquoi le ministère ne vous plaisait
pas au contraire
au contraire non j'avais l'intérieur je
le voulais d'accord en juin 2012 au
contraire c'est un vrai ministère pour
la gauche c'est un vrai ministère pour
l'histoire de la gauche et ses répliques
du travail du dialogue social de
l'emploi d'un gouvernement de gauche
socialistes bon quand on est moi j'en
avais rêvé donc quand j'étais plus jeune
voilà donc pour pouvoir agir pour
pouvoir et d'eau que je me suis dit à un
moment je peux pas rester en dehors les
bras croisés et puis critiquer et dire
il faut passer de pédagogie à moi de
chypre et de ma part voilà alors c'est
personne a raison c c'est pas facile
j'ai combien c'est pas facile c'est vrai
que voilà mes yeux regarde toujours dix
jours quand même être les yeux de
chimène je commençais c'est ça la
question la question beaucoup de gens se
posent même dire que les rumeurs qui
courent à dijon les en réalité française
semaines il continue à être maire de
cette ville non je continue à informer à
tenir informés à venir la preuve le plus
souvent possible le week end à suivre
les dossiers à être en échange permanent
avec alain millot
elle soutenir dans toutes les démarches
nationale qu'il fait et donc au conseil
je pense qu'on fait un bon duo mois la
hausse que je peux apporter à dijon
c'est ce que j'essaye de faire bien
évidemment
et soutenir mais c'est lui le maire
vient droit la drogue avait beaucoup dit
pardon pardonnez moi pendant la campagne
vous allez dire quelqu'un qui sera pas
votre mère il avait raison oui mais je
ne savais pas ce que j'allais faire je
viens de vous le dire d'ailleurs savez
pas d'avoir si on aime proposer quelque
chose et puis et puis je reviendrai donc
ce que l'engagement que j'ai pris
c'est que je serai à nouveau je le pense
maire de dijon avant la fin de ce mandat
municipal et mon rêve le plus cher je le
dis comme ça j'ai présenté comme ça
c'est transmettre avec alan iud m soit
le plus cher c'est transmettre le
flambeau à quelqu'un de plus jeune
nathan vient le très bon et c'est vous
qui commencez la phrase alors elle les
temps viendront à quelqu'un de plus
jeune à quelqu'un de plus jeune elle
sera difficile la succession oui c'est
toujours difficile bien sûr c'est
toujours difficile mais il ya beaucoup
de jeunes qui sont rentrés dans l'équipe
la glisse on dans l'équipe et qui j'en
suis sûr on aime amour parce qu'il faut
vraiment de sa ville pour être maire
d'une même si vous n'êtes pas mais
actuellement ce manga c'est vous qui
l'avez n'en sait donc vous allez pouvoir
répondre à cette question il ya eu
beaucoup de grandes choses en terme de
visibilité dans les deux premiers
mandats
on a l'impression qu'il a beaucoup moins
dans le troisième c'est quoi ce
troisième mandat damas et c'est la
continuité des engagements qui avaient
été pris regardez le stade de football
la tribune mais surtout des choses qui
ne se voient pas mais qui vont faire
passer dans la modernité des gens je
pense alors que j'ai vu qu'il y avait
des sous qui osaient critiquer ça la
mise en place d'un réseau de chaleur
c'est c'est quelque chose de formidable
c'est la fin des chaudières au fioul
moins visible
pour la qualité de vie c'est très
important oui on fait pas des trams tous
les jours pour le moment il faut
rembourser la dette pour le tram ce que
fait le grand dijon très bien et puis
ils se transforment et évoluent et ça
sera la communauté urbaine alors c'est
ça c'est une belle belle réussite chez
initié à la muse a fait voter il nous
reste une poignée de minutes avant de
continuer on vient de me dire dans
l'oreillette andré bergeron ancien
leader syndical est décédé
ça vient de tomber sur les agences c'est
une époque sein du syndicalisme et c'est
une autre époque qu'aujourd'hui bien sûr
je connaissais andré bergeron j'ai connu
blondel
à l'époque il y avait comme une dizaine
du grain à moudre voilà mais c'étaient
des grandes syndicaliste il y en a aussi
aujourd'hui
jean claude mailly est quelqu'un de tout
à fait
respectable et qui portent haut son
organisation syndicale je préférerais
qu'il soit quand même plus à lens sur
les accords qui passe avec moi avec avec
le barça il reste une poignée de minutes
avec un peu plus de sourires on s'était
dit qu'on allait vous recevoir avec un
livre on a beaucoup dit vous vous alliez
sortir un livre dont le concept
interpellé beaucoup les rapports entre
le le football la politique vous l'avez
pas fini
en plus j'étais j'ai reçu des lettres a
su ce que je vais vous dire est ce que
vous avez eu peur de l'effet que ça
allait faire deux derniers du travail ou
les occuper du chômage il écrit des
bouquins sur le fauchage dit j'ai eu
droit ce qu'ils savent pas si je l'avais
écrit que j'étais au sénat ce qui était
quand même en droit le plus strict donc
je gardais la coupe du monde à venir
donc qui s'est déroulée au dernier
trimestre pour compléter le dernier
chapitre de ce livre et je vais vous
faire un aveu les gens avaient raison
j'ai pas le temps d'écrire et donc il
est écrit aux trois quarts et il me
manque la coupe du monde vous lors des
sorties quand même en dépit du torrent
de lettres vous avez reçus oui j'avais
le temps de noël de le faire donc
maintenant je me dis je vais à repousser
il y aura l'euro 2016 après tout
personne ne peut m'empêcher quand même
car non mais mais quelques jours de
repos à noël où on était de terminer on
voit pas football politique justement je
vais regarder là le secret c'est c'est
un peu autobiographique bien sûr c'est
mon histoire mêlés à des événements
sportifs qui se déroule comme ça qui
permettent de rythme et le temps alors
cette conduite commencé en 1958 parce
que j'étais première coupe du monde que
j'ai vu à la télévision et ça ce set est
censée se terminer à celle là mais
finalement ça va me donner le temps
d'introduire un nouvel événement je ne
sais pas que vous aviez pas tellement
envie de terminer à celle là parce que
le contexte potentiellement jeu ou sur
un aveu d'abord j'ai eu droit nos jours
de congés cet été au mois d'août et j'ai
dormi 48 heures et j'ai pas eu le
courage de gpo le courage de tenter
quelque chose pendant les sept jours de
faire que ça et puis aussi consacrer un
peu de temps sa famille alors sans nous
livrer les bonnes feuilles cette france
en crise actuelle pendant la coupe du
monde qu'on a vécu là votre point de vue
ça dit quoi c'est une phase de
transition qui allait amener à la
victoire à l'euro 2016 vont faire après
exactement comme il nous reste très peu
de temps il nous reste deux minutes et
demie juste un tout petit mot vous avez
été président du groupe au sénat puis le
sénat il est perdu pour la gauche après
l'émission à dire ça alors que françois
patriat fait une campagne du de feu de
dieu du tonnerre là sur le terrain donc
très difficile pour rapatrier dit lui
même qui aura probablement qu'un seul
siège au lieu de 2 pour la gauche en
côte-d'or je pense que son secret espoir
et la raison c'est d'en avoir deux c'est
tout ce que je peux lui souhaiter en
tous les cas elle le mériterait vu la
campagne qui fait pas tout seul il ya
isabelle lajoux il ya patrick molinoz
ils sont la peste et là ils sont tous là
derrière donc fait une belle campagne
mériterait d'avoir les deux ciel mais
apprécié les électeurs qui choisissent
et qui tranche ce sera plus clair
finalement c'est la gauche par le sénat
est ce que ce sera pas tout l'air d'une
certaine manière cette majorité certains
qualifiaient d' banque albert moux
oui elle n'était pas simple n'était pas
simple il n'y avait pas de majorité de
facto il y avait une majorité de gauche
mais avec des élus communistes qu'il
votait plus rien avec nous donc
elle était mais je pense qu'une vraie
majorité de droite ça va être un
handicap pour le gouvernement il faut
qu'il fasse attention les grands
électeurs à ne pas réintroduire un sénat
de pure opposition merci françois
rebsamen
de nous avoir donné un petit peu de
temps je le disais en ouverture dans
l'agenda de la ministre
samedi prochain pas d'émission puisque
nous serons à moins de 24 heures des
élections sénatoriales le sénat dont
nous avons parlé et je voterai
et vous
aurez peut-être
mais vous pourrez suivre une page
spéciale dans le journal de mercredi à
vendredi pour tout savoir sur ces
élections et puis les résultats dimanche
bien sûr dans notre journal de 19h bon
week-end au revoir et merci